- Here to perform their Viennese Waltz
from Dancing with the Stars,
give it up for Sasha
Farber and Ally Brooke.
(audience cheers)
(mellow piano music)
♪ And I'd give up forever to touch you ♪
♪ 'Cause I know that you feel me somehow ♪
♪ You're the closest to
heaven that I'll ever be ♪
♪ And I don't wanna go home right now ♪
♪ All I can taste is this moment ♪
♪ And all I can breathe is your life ♪
♪ Sooner or later it's over ♪
♪ I just don't wanna miss you tonight ♪
♪ And I don't want the world to see me ♪
♪ 'Cause I don't think
that they'd understand ♪
♪ When everything's meant to be broken ♪
♪ I just want you to know who I am ♪
(audience cheers)
- Oh my gosh!
(clapping)
- Thank you.
- Come up here, oh my gosh!
- Go stand over here,
come over here.
That was incredible.
- Thank you.
- Isn't she good?
- [Mike] Very good.
- [Kelly] She, we, you
were both really good.
God, that was so graceful!
- He's the best partner.
- [Mike] Unbelievable.
- How's Ally been doing?
(laughs)
- She is literally a dream partner.
She comes in--
- Thank you.
- So dedicated, her passion.
I mean, I've known Ally for a while now
and maybe two or three years
ago I saw her at The Grove,
and I was like, "That's Ally!"
And I ran up to her and I was like,
"We would be perfect
"in Dancing with the Stars."
- Isn't that crazy?
I remember that.
- And then look
what happened?
- It was crazy.
- [Kelly] Oh my gosh, oh my gosh!
(audience applauds)
- Look what happened!
- [Kelly] Oh my gosh!
- Look what happened, guys!
- That's really great!
Okay, can you show me and
Mike some of your moves?
I wanna learn some of it.
- Oh, what?
- Yes!
- Oh boy!
- What?
- Come on, Sasha!
- I'm not gonna lie.
- I'm not afraid!
- I'm like freakin' out
a little bit
- Okay, okay, all right.
- 'cause I'm a huge fan.
- All right.
- (laughs) Okay!
- Don't make me look bad.
- Okay.
- [Sasha] So, we're gonna do
a little Viennese Waltz, so.
- Okay.
- I'm totally gonna
kick your tail.
(upbeat orchestral music)
- So, we're gonna do the
opposites to me, right?
- Okay.
- So you're gonna step to,
you're gonna step that way.
- Yes.
- And we're gonna step this way.
- Okay.
- So we're gonna go,
one, two, three.
- Ball change.
- Ball change, look at that.
- One, two, three.
Look at this.
- Okay, okay.
- That's pretty good.
- Get out of my arm movement, Mike.
- Should we--
- We're in our space,
my arms are long.
- Get out of my arm space.
- (laughs) I'm just kidding!
- This is called Floorcraft.
This is called Floorcraft.
So let's do two of those,
are you ready?
- Stagger!
- You guys got that pretty quick.
- Stagger, I grew up in musical theater.
(laughs)
- Yes, queen!
- Okay, oh ready?
- So we're gonna go.
- Oh sure.
- Seven and we go arms.
- Out, two three.
- One, two, three.
- Hey.
- Two, hey!
(audience applauds)
- Look at that!
Wait, wait, wait, we're not done yet.
We're not done yet
- No, we're not done
there's more.
- Okay.
- And then from there
I'm gonna demonstrate with Ally.
- Okay.
- She's gonna go from the last one,
she's gonna step to the side.
- Right, left.
- And big!
- Ooh.
- Big finish,
big finish.
- Right, left, big finish.
- Big finish.
- Yes!
- Okay.
- Really go into that--
- I'm gonna lunge like
- One at a time,
- I don't wanna hit Kelly
- Richard Simmons, okay?
- I don't wanna hit Kelly,
- Right?
(audience cheers)
- [Mike] You've got enough space?
- [Ally] Richard Simmons.
- So let's go from the beginning, right?
- [Mike] Beginning, okay.
- Okay.
- We need applause, come on guys.
- [Kelly] Yes!
(audience applauds)
- Help, help us out.
- So guys, seven
- [Kelly And Sasha] and one, two, three,
two to three.
- Nice, here, we go, we change our arms.
- And we're and--
- [Kelly And Sasha] Lunge!
- Whoa!
(audience applauds)
- [Kelly] You pulled me (laughs).
- I got you, I got you.
- I totally almost went down!
You're a good--